♪ ♪
>> Bret: LET’S GET SOME
INSIGHT NOW FROM SENIOR
PRESIDENTIAL ADVISOR
JARED KUSHNER.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS PEACE
DEAL BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE UAE,
WE HEARD THE PRESIDENT TALKING
ABOUT IT -- I WONDER IF YOU
COULD LIFT THE VEIL ABOUT HOW WE
AS A COUNTRY GOT HERE.
>> IT’S GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY.
BEING IN WASHINGTON, THERE ARE A
LOT OF DAYS WHERE YOU SEE A LOT
OF PROCESS AND POSTURING BUT
IT’S VERY RARE THAT YOU HAVE A
DAY WHERE YOU CAN TRULY
CELEBRATE A HISTORIC ACHIEVEMENT
THAT WILL CHANGE THE COURSE OF A
REGION AND THE WORLD.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE PRESENT
STARTED ON.
WE WENT TO SAUDI ARABIA IN MAY
OF 2017, I BELIEVE YOU WERE
THERE AND AT THAT SPEECH, THE
PRESIDENT LAID OUT A NEW VISION
FOR THE REGION.
SINCE THEN, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
TAKEN BACK THE TERRITORIAL
CALIPHATE OF ISIS, HE’S KILLED
SEVERAL OF THE TERRORIST
LEADERS, HE’S BROUGHT THE REGION
TOGETHER, TO ALIGN THEM AROUND
SHARED INTERESTS AND MAKE SURE
THEY CAN COMBAT COMMON THREATS.
THIS IS A INTENSE SET UP WITH
DIPLOMACY AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS SET THE STAGE IN THE
MIDDLE EAST TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
HISTORIC BREAKTHROUGH, I BELIEVE
IT CAN HAPPEN IN THE MONTHS AND
YEARS AHEAD.
>> Bret: HE SUGGESTED THERE
MAY BE OTHER COUNTRIES ON BOARD,
ARE THEY?
>> A LOT OF INTEREST FROM A LOT
OF COUNTRIES, PEOPLE ARE OFTEN
AFRAID TO GO FIRST.
SO FAR IT’S BEEN VERY POSITIVE
AND A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE DON’T
WANT TO FOCUS ON PAST CONFLICTS,
THEY WANT TO FOCUS ON HOW THEY
CAN HAVE A BETTER FUTURE, THEY
WANT SECURITY, THEY WANT
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY, THEY ARE
BOTH TECHNOLOGY POWERHOUSES AND
SECURITY POWERHOUSES.
THIS IS A GREAT ALIGNMENT AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP BUILD TRUST
AFTER THE LAST ADMINISTRATION,
BOTH PARTIES HAD FELT DOWN ON
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH AMERICA,
THEY FELT BETRAYED AFTER THE
IRAN DEAL WHICH SENT
$150 BILLION TO IRAN AND THEY
USE THAT MONEY TO FUND A LOT OF
THE PROXIES THAT WERE
DESTABILIZING THE REGION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS REBUILT THAT
TRUST, HE’S BROUGHT THEM CLOSER
TOGETHER AND ALIGNED THEM AROUND
A COMMON VISION THAT CAN BE
GOOD.
SOMEBODY SAID TO ME VERY EARLY
ON WHEN I GOT THIS ASSIGNMENT,
YOU DON’T LOSE MONEY BETTING
AGAINST SUCCESS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST BUT I ALSO SAID YOU
CAN LOSE A LOT OF MONEY BETTING
AGAINST TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO DO IT
IN AN UNCONVENTIONAL WAY AND BY
DOING IT, HE HAS ACHIEVED A
HISTORIC RESULT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ANOTHER QUESTION ABOUT THIS AND
I WANT TO ASK YOU TO LISTEN TO
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU AND HIS
COMMENTS THIS AFTERNOON.
>> THIS IS THE GREATEST
ADVANCEMENT TOWARD PEACE BETWEEN
ISRAEL AND THE ARAB WORLD AND
THE LAST 26 YEARS, THIS IS THE
FUTURE OF PEACE, FUTURE OF
SECURITY, AND THE FUTURE OF
PROSPERITY.
>> Bret: WENT TO THE
PRIME MINISTER FINALLY AGREED TO
HOLD OFF ON ANNEXATION AND DO
YOU HAVE A SENSE FOR HOW LONG
THIS PAUSE IS GOING TO BE?
>> WE BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT WHAT
ANNEXATION WOULD LOOK LIKE FOR
THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
THE PRIME MINISTER IS A HISTORIC
LEADER, HE’S A VISIONARY, HE WAS
ABLE TO AGREE TO A TWO STATE
SOLUTION WITH THE PALESTINIANS
ON THE BASIS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S VISION FOR
PEACE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THIS PLAN BECAUSE BY
IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN, WE WOULD
BE SAVING THE TWO STATE
SOLUTION, NOT DESTROYING IT
WHICH WOULD BE A MASSIVE CHANGE.
FOR THE LAST SIX WEEKS, THE
NOTION OF NORMALIZATION IN LIEU
OF A ISRAEL SOVEREIGNTY CAME UP
AND PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU DID
THE CALCULUS AND SAW THIS WAS
MUCH MORE IN THE INTEREST OF
ISRAEL IN THE
SHORT-MEDIUM-LONG TERM.
THAT’S WHAT LEADERS DO, THEY PUT
POLITICS ASIDE AND THEY MAKE THE
DECISION TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
COUNTRY AND KEEP THEIR PEOPLE
SAFE.
>> Bret: YOU JUST HEARD OUR
NEW FOX NEWS POLL WITH FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN LEADING BY
SEVEN POINTS.
IN THE JOB PERFORMANCE, THE
PRESIDENT IS AT 44% DISAPPROVE,
54% AND WHO IS TRUSTED TO DO A
BETTER JOB ON DIFFERENT ISSUES,
THE PRESIDENT IS UP THREE ON THE
ECONOMY BUT HE IS LOSING TO
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN ON A NUMBER
OF KEY ISSUES, WHERE DO YOU SEE
THIS RACE RIGHT NOW?
>> WE’VE SPOKEN ABOUT THE
METHODOLOGY OF THE FOX POLL’S
AND WE SAW A LOT OF THE LAST
ELECTION OUT OF 120 POLLS
CONDUCTED IN MICHIGAN,
WISCONSIN, AND PENNSYLVANIA
BETWEEN LABOR DAY AND THE
ELECTION, ONLY ONE SHOWED
PRESIDENT TRUMP AHEAD.
THESE POLES ARE BASED OFF OF
FLAWED METHODOLOGY.
OUR POLLS SHOW THE PRESIDENT IS
LEADING IN A LOT OF THE STATES
THAT HE WON LAST TIME AND WE
WERE JUST IN OHIO, THE
PRESIDENT WON OHIO BY EIGHT AND
A HALF POINTS, HE BELIEVES HE’S
GOING TO WIN BY MORE THIS TIME
AND IF YOU GO YOU GO STATE BY
STATE AND LOOK AT VOTER TURNOUT
MODELS CAN BE LOOKED AT THE
ENTHUSIASM, WE ARE SEEING
ENCOURAGING SIGNS ON THE GROUND
AND WE THINK THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY LOVE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING AND
THEY WANT TO SEE HIM BACK IN
OFFICE FOR FOUR MORE YEARS SO HE
CAN CONTINUE TO REBUILD THE
ECONOMY AND FINISH THE JOB THAT
HE STARTED.
>> Bret: YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
LIKELY VOTERS, NOT REGISTERED
VOTERS, YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
SAMPLE THAT MATCHES HOW YOU SEE
OF THE ELECTION SHAPING UP BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE REAL CLEAR
POLITICS AVERAGE, JOE BIDEN IS
UP SEVEN AND HALF POINTS, IT’S
AN AVERAGE OF RECENT POLLS
ACROSS THE BOARD AND THE AVERAGE
AND BATTLEGROUNDS COME YOU CAN
SEE BIDEN WITH THE LEAD.
I GET THAT YOU DON’T LIKE POLLS
AT THIS POINT --
>> President Trump: WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS ON ELECTION DAY
LAST YEAR, EVERYONE THOUGHT IT
WAS GOING TO BE A LANDSLIDE, I
WAS LOOKING AT OUR DATA END OF
THE DATA SHOWED THAT TRUMP WAS
GOING TO WIN THE LANDSLIDE.
A LOT OF THOSE POLLS ARE USING A
24% REPUBLICAN TURNOUT MODEL,
BUT IN 2018 AND 2016, IT WAS
33%.
I DON’T KNOW WHY COMPANIES ARE
SPENDING MONEY ON THESE POLLS
BECAUSE IT’S NOT SCIENTIFIC AND
NOT INDICATIVE OF WHAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
>> Bret: WE CAN TALK ABOUT
FULL METHODOLOGY AND AS WE GET
CLOSER, WE WILL GET A DIFFERENT
MIND-SET AS WE LOOK AT THOSE.
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THESE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE POST OFFICE
AND FUNDING THE POST OFFICE,
SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN THAT
BRIEFING.
IF THE CRITICS ARE SAYING AFTER
HIS INTERVIEW TODAY THAT HE’S
BRAZENLY ATTEMPTING WHAT THEY
SAY TO STEAL THE ELECTION BY
INVALIDATING A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS OR THAT HE DELIBERATELY
IS DAMAGING THE POST OFFICE TO
SOMEHOW CHANGE THE ELECTION.
ADDRESS THAT FROM THAT CHARGE
THAT THE CRITICS ARE GIVING.
>> ONE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP’S MANY
SKILLS AS HE GETS HIS CRITICS TO
GO CRAZY ON ALL TYPES OF THINGS
THAT ENDS UP MAKING HIS POINT.
ALL HE’S TRYING TO SAY IS THERE
ARE SOME STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
DOING MAIL IN BALLOTS IN
DIFFERENT FORMS WHETHER IT’S
ABSENTEE BALLOT AND THEY ARE
DOING IT APPROPRIATELY.
IF YOU’RE TRYING TO RUSH A WHOLE
SYSTEM, ALL THE RECENT EXAMPLES
ARE SHOWING IT DOESN’T WORK.
IT’S LIKE SAYING WE ARE TRUSTING
THE POST OFFICE TO BE THE MOST
EFFICIENT ARBITER OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
BRING ATTENTION TO AN ISSUE AND
IT IS A BIG ISSUE.
WE SAW THAT IN NEW YORK AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST WANTS A
FAIR AND WELL-RUN ELECTION AND
HE’S WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT HAPPENS.
>> Bret: ANOTHER THING SETTING
OFF THE CRITICS IS YOU AND
IVANKA MEETING WITH KANYE WEST
IN COLORADO.
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AND
THERE ARE CHARGES THAT THIS IS A
COORDINATED PLAN TO SOMEHOW
SIPHON BLACK VOTES AWAY FROM
JOE BIDEN, HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT?
>> UNLIKE OTHERS, UNABLE TO KEEP
FRIENDSHIPS ACROSS THE AISLE,
KANYE HAS BEEN A FRIEND FOR TEN
YEARS, HE’S A SPECIAL PERSON,
HE’S A SUCCESSFUL MUSIC ARTIST,
SUCCESSFUL DESIGNER, HE’S BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN A LOT OF THE
THINGS HE HAS DONE.
WE WERE TOGETHER IN THE SAME
SPOT, HE SENT ME A BOOK ABOUT A
MONTH AGO CALLED POWER PHNOM
ECONOMICS, IT INCORPORATED A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN DOING
THAT IT’S SOMETHING I’VE
DISTRIBUTED MORE COPIES TO MY
DOMESTIC POLICY TEAM.
THERE’S A LOT OF INSPIRATION WE
CAN GET FROM IT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S SECOND TERM
AGENDA.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IDEAS AND
FRIENDSHIPS THAT SHOULD TRUMP
POLITICS.
>> Bret: DO YOU KNOW THE
CHARGES THAT REPUBLICAN
OPERATIVES ARE HELPING HIM
TRYING TO GET ON THESE BALLOTS,
IS THAT’S TRUE?
>> WE DIDN’T DISCUSS HIS
CAMPAIGN AND WHAT HE’S UP TO.
I READ THINGS IN THE PRESS BUT I
HAVE NOT DISCUSSED THAT DIRECTLY
WITH HIM.
>> Bret: YOU DON’T KNOW THAT
THIS HAPPENING.
>> I’VE LEARNED IN FIVE YEARS
NOW, JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS
SET IN THE MEDIA, DOESN’T MEAN
IT’S TRUE.
I LIKE TO INVESTIGATE THE FACTS
AND IN LESS I FEEL LIKE
SOMETHING IS VERIFIED, I TEND
NOT TO ASSUME.
>> Bret: WHO’S REALLY IN
CHARGE OF THE CAMPAIGN?
THERE ARE SOME WHO ARE SAYING
YOU’RE STILL THE DEFECTIVE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALWAYS
BEEN IN CHARGE OF THE CAMPAIGN
AND HE ALWAYS WILL BE IN CHARGE
OF THE CAMPAIGN.
MY JOB IS TO HELP HIM MAKE SURE
THAT HE HAS GOOD OPTIONS FOR
PEOPLE AROUND HIM AND PEOPLE WHO
CAN EXECUTE.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE OVER 1500
PEOPLE IN THE FIELD, A MILLION
AND A HALF VOLUNTEERS.
WE HAVE A TREMENDOUS
ORGANIZATION, THE FUND-RAISING
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A VERY STRONG
OPERATION BUT THAT’S BECAUSE OF
HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS VISION.
HE SETS THE MESSAGE AND SETS THE
TONE, HE DECIDES WHAT HE WANTS
TO GO AND HE’S GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WHO HELP HIM
EXECUTE THAT.
>> Bret: YOU SAID HE LIKES TO
STIR UP HIS CRITICS.
AT THAT PRESS BRIEFING, HE
SEEMED TO GIVE CREDENCE TO A
"NEWSWEEK" OP-ED TO THE QUESTION
THE ELIGIBILITY OF KAMALA HARRIS
BEING ABLE TO RUN FOR
VICE PRESIDENT -- WHY DO THAT?
>> I’VE BEEN OUT HERE WAITING TO
DO YOUR SHOW SO I HAVEN’T SEEN
THAT, I HAVEN’T SEEN THE OP-ED.
I’LL RESERVE JUDGMENT UNTIL I
KNOW MORE ABOUT IT.
>> Bret: SHE WAS BORN IN
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA, TO INDIAN
AND JAMAICAN IMMIGRANTS, SHE’S A
NATURAL BORN CITIZEN -- ANYWAY,
DO YOU SEE THIS ELECTION THAT
YOU ARE LOSING RIGHT NOW I’M A
OR DO YOU SEE YOU HAVE TO MAKE
UP GROUND BEFORE NOVEMBER 3RD?
HOW DO YOU SEE IT PLAYING OUT
OVER 82 DAYS?
>> I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN
A MUCH BETTER POSITION NOW THAN
HE WAS GOING INTO THE LAST
CAMPAIGN.
HE SPENT AN UNDERDOG ALL HIS
LIFE -- TAKE THE PEACE DEAL FOR
INSTANCE, NOBODY THOUGHT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
IT SHOWS PRESIDENT TRUMP’S STYLE
IS THAT HE DOESN’T THINK IN
NONTRADITIONAL WAYS, HE MAKES
PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE, HE TAKES
DIFFERENT APPROACHES, MAYBE HE
USES PEOPLE, YOU WOULDN’T THINK
WOULD BE THE NORMAL PEOPLE TO DO
IT BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, HE
GETS RESULTS IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE LIKE RESULTS AND THEY
WANT RESULTS FROM THEIR LEADERS.
I THINK THEY ARE TIRED OF
POLITICIANS WHO TALK AND TALK --
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BROUGHT
TO WASHINGTON IS ACCOUNTABILITY,
HE’S BROUGHT ACTION.
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON ANY
ISSUE, YOU DON’T HAVE TO WONDER
WHAT HIS POLICY IS COME YOU
DON’T HAVE TO WONDER WHAT HE’S
THINKING.
LOOK AT TWITTER AND HIS PRESS
CONFERENCES, HE’S THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENT AND PEOPLE
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO GET
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND I THINK
AMERICA WANTS TO SEE HIM BE THE
PERSON WHO’S GOING TO REBUILD
THE COUNTRY AFTER THE
CORONAVIRUS AND KEEP DOING THE
GREAT POLICIES THAT HE HAS BEEN
DOING.
TODAY’S HISTORIC AGREEMENT
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE UAE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LEADERSHIP,
THE TRUSTEE IS BUILT WITH OUR
ALLIES IN THE MIDDLE EAST IS A
MUCH SAFER PLACE THAN ONE
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME INTO OFFICE
FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> Bret: NO DOUBT A BIG